[MUSIC PLAYING]
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Hello, my
name is Ahmet Alp Balkan.
I work on the Google
Kubernetes Engine,
so my job is to basically
make Kubernetes Engine easier
to understand to developers
and defend developers'
choices within Google.
Previously, I
worked at Microsoft.
I maintain several
Kubernetes-related open source
projects.
YOSHI TAMURA: And
my name is Yoshi.
This is my third
talk in this niche,
so I'm glad I'm making it.
I work on multi--
I'm a product manager in
the Kubernetes Engine,
and I work on
multi-tenancy, including--
I just gave a speech on gVisor
Sandbox and the hardware
accelerator, like a
machine learning workload,
like in using GPU and Cloud
TPU, all in Kubernetes Engine.
OK.
So let's jump into the topic.
So we're going to
cover multi-tenancy,
a practical thing in
the Kubernetes Engine.
Kubernetes, I've
been talking, as I
think everyone knows
this, because even
in keynote Kubernetes was
mentioned so many times.
It's everywhere and
quite pervasive.
As a consequence, I think large
teams, large organizations,
have also adopted Kubernetes
and also Kubernetes Engine
as a result, which is great.
And then when large teams and
large organizations come to us,
and, OK, I want to
use Kubernetes Engine.
Cool.
And people call ask
a common question.
So I'm a large organization,
have multiple teams,
and with multiple requirements.
How can we actually use
Kubernetes Engine and cluster
with multiple teams?
This is actually a very, very
kind of a complex question,
because answering
to how you do it,
there are so many actually ways.
And honestly, we thought
because there are so many ways,
we actually wanted to
ask you a question.
And so we created a link here,
gke.page.link/multi-tenancy.
You will see the questions.
I'm going to show this link
later at the top, so no rush.
But I think multi-tenancy
is something
that it's still
emerging in Kubernetes,
and we're trying to [INAUDIBLE]
into Kubernetes Engine.
So we will love to
hear your opinion
about what are you are doing,
and what do you want to do,
and where you want
to go as well.
To give you what I'm trying
to get to about the complexity
and challenge of
multi-tenancy, this
is really the kind of overview.
We're going to cover
this, but these
are the kind of areas that
you want to consider before
or to answer to the
original question.
How can I share GKE,
you know, my Kubernetes
Engine among multiple teams?
And Ahmet, our great
instructor, is here
to guide you what
you can actually
do with the primitives and the
principles that we have today.
So back to Ahmet.
AHMET ALP BALKAN:
Thank you, Yoshi.
All right, so we're going to
talk about a lot of things
today.
It may seem like we're
jumping from topic to topic,
but it's going to be YAML heavy.
So I'm assuming this is
an intermediate audience
for adults familiar
with Kubernetes.
In this talk, I want to show
you the practical aspects
of multi-tenancy
that, you know, you
can go home and start using.
But first, we must
define the terminology
that we're going to use.
And I want to start with
what is multi-tenancy?
And in the software
context, the multi-tenancy
means a single of software
running somewhere,
and it serves multiple
tenants, right?
You can simply say, any
websites that you folks
are using probably is a
multi-tenant software, right?
So today's topic is
Kubernetes, and that's
why we're going to
talk about Kubernetes
as a multi-tenant
system and analyze it.
In Kubernetes' terms,
Kubernetes' multi-tenancy
is providing isolation
and fair resource
sharing between multiple
users in a single cluster.
This part is important.
It's important that it
is in a single cluster.
So at the end,
we're going to talk
about how the multiple
tenants in a single cluster
live happily without stepping
on each other's toes.
And before we talk
about multi-tenancy,
I first want to talk about
trust and why is it important.
So let's go through
these things.
Anyone here completely
trust all these things
in their deployment pipelines?
Like, they totally trust it?
I don't think so.
So a lot of things that you
use to deploy your software,
run your software, or
build your software mostly
comes from people that you
don't exactly know, right?
There are papers,
scientific papers,
that I cited on
the bottom right.
You can take a look at it
about trusting compilers.
And, you know, verifiable
operating systems
is a space on its own.
And then mostly
you would probably
use open source dependencies,
and your deployment pipeline
is probably Jenkins
or something else.
And then there are
container runtimes
that you folks are using.
Docker is, for instance,
or Containerd, or whatever.
So do you actually
trust these runtimes?
So it's not a binary
or anything like that.
It's not a binary choice.
It's mostly like you're probably
somewhere on the spectrum.
So we classify these levels
of software multi-tenancy
in terms of trusted,
semi-trusted, and non-trusted.
So in the trusted
case, everything
comes from an audited
source repository, right?
It's basically pretty
much what Google does,
and the compiler is trusted.
The build system is trusted,
and even some of the hardware
is trusted.
But most people are
not there, right?
Most of us are probably in some
place that is semi-trusted.
We have some trust
components that we rely on,
and we build our security
models around it.
So now, let's talk about
some of the Kubernetes Engine
multi-tenancy primitives.
If you're already doing
multi-tenancy today,
you're probably
segmenting your tenants
in your clusters probably
based on either creating
a separate cluster
for each tenant
or creating a namespace
for each tenant.
And both options
can be OK, and let's
dive into how are
they different.
In the cluster per
tenant case, you're
basically creating
separate control planes.
By control plane, I
mean the Kubernetes API.
Anytime you run kubectl
get or something
like that, you hit the
Kubernetes control plane.
In this case, just because
there are separate clusters,
you've got a separate
control plane.
And you might actually be
getting separate networks
as well, if every cluster
lives its own VPC,
virtual private network, right?
This can be still
useful if you're
separating your clusters between
dev stage and production.
However, this has
some shortcomings,
such as if you have
a lot of users,
then you need tools
that let you manage
tens and hundreds of clusters.
And potentially, this is
not a fun job to be at.
And you need to worry
about the fragmentation
issues, the diverging
configuration that
happens in the cluster.
And every time someone
asks for a runtime,
you need to go actually
provision that cluster.
However, namespace is a
little bit better than that,
and it's mostly because
Kubernetes is basically
providing a lot
of policy objects
that are native to
Kubernetes namespaces.
So namespace is
the building block
that lets us build our
multi-tenant infrastructure
on Kubernetes.
And again, the pros of
this is that anytime
you run a cluster with multiple
tenants, any configuration
or setting or, you know,
off-time reliability
concerns that you apply to that
cluster is shared by everyone.
Anytime you add an
add-on, extension
is, again, shared by everyone.
And in this case, since you're
sharing the control plane,
they'll benefit from the
same security measures.
So you know, we're going to
talk about a lot of Kubernetes
security primitives today.
I just listed some of them here.
I mainly categorize them
under access control,
resource isolation,
and runtime isolation.
And actually, we're going
to recategorize them later.
So now let's evaluate
some of the common use
cases with Kubernetes
multi-tenancy,
like what are the
things that you
might be doing so
that you would require
a multi-tenant
environment on Kubernetes?
We're going to look at
three different models.
One of them is Enterprise,
where you're in a company
and every team is
potentially a tenant.
And then there is the
Software as a Service, which
most users don't actually
see in Kubernetes,
but the infrastructure
still runs on Kubernetes.
And then there's Kubernetes as a
Service, where you're basically
accepting workloads from
people that you don't know.
So let's focus on the
Enterprise model first.
In the Enterprise
model, all users
are from the same company.
So if anybody is
doing something wrong,
you can go fire them, right?
In this case, everybody
gets its own namespace.
In the diagram you
can see up here,
there is a cluster
admin that potentially
has the full permissions
on the cluster.
And then there
are various users.
Each emoji here is a different
team, and then in a team,
there is a Namespace Admin
that has a little bit more
permissions on that namespace.
So to achieve these
personas, we're
looking at creating
cluster roles.
So again, the Cluster
Admin has full admin.
Namespace Admin manages the
users in that namespace.
And then the user
basically can apply,
let's say, pods and workloads
and load balancers and stuff
like that.
But they cannot actually
edit the policies.
So we're going to come
back to the policies later.
In this case, all
the source code
is coming from a
single code repository,
such as your company's source
depots, maybe a vanilla
container isolation you get
with Containerd or Docker
or something like
that might be OK.
But if it's not, if
you're running components
that you don't trust
much, you might
be considering to
run on something
like gVisor for Sandboxing.
Or you can use Linux
security primitives,
such as seccomp, AppArmor,
SELinux, and stuff like that.
So as far as the network
isolation is concerned,
we're going to come back to
how network isolation is done,
but I basically want to say
that each namespace probably
should be able to talk to
anything in that namespace.
And outside that
namespace, you should
be worried about who's calling
your applications, right?
So the next thing
I'm going to touch
is the Software as
a Service model.
This is a little bit different.
Basically, in this
case, the consumer
deploys their app through
a custom control plane.
So the users of your
Software as a Service
does not know Kubernetes much.
Maybe they are not actually
seeing Kubernetes at all.
In this case, after
they deploy your app,
after they deploy
their app, they're
basically connecting
to the app directly,
so they're not seeing
Kubernetes in the middle at all.
So Kubernetes is, in this case,
is an implementation detail.
So this is not very interesting
to Kubernetes, actually.
An example of this
can be, you can
imagine WordPress.com
anytime you've probably
assumed that, theoretically,
you go to WordPress.com.
You create a blog, and
then WordPress.com probably
creates some pods for you.
And then you directly talk
to your WordPress admin
page, right?
You don't see Kubernetes
in the middle.
But someone, in this
case, the Cluster Admin,
has access to the
Kubernetes API.
And basically,
there is a SaaS API
that is a trusted
client of Kubernetes.
So in this case,
the tenant workload
can actually have
untrusted pieces.
And let's say you
have a WordPress blog,
and you are
installing extensions.
And extensions are potentially
arbitrary code execution,
right?
So in this case, you
may require something
like Sandboxing again, with
gVisor or some other runtime.
And the last model that
we're going to look at
is the Kubernetes
as a Service model.
You can call this containers
as a service as well.
You know, you're running
a hosting company
that you're accepting
containers from everybody.
What can go wrong?
In this case, tenants,
again, you know,
have different link spaces.
But in this case, they're
not seeing each other at all.
So you have a little bit more
stronger isolation requirements
than the Enterprise or the
SaaS that we looked at.
And the isolation of
[INAUDIBLE] can easily
be achieved with something
like Kubernetes RBAC.
Again, the network
isolation requires stuff
like the Sandbox pods and
the multi-tenant networking
so that people are
actually not stepping
on each other's networking
and potentially snooping
on each other's networking.
So let's talk a little bit about
what are these policy objects
and features that
Kubernetes provides to us
so that we can use them in our
companies and in our clusters.
So we've previously talked about
these features, like admission
control, RBAC, and quotas,
and pod security policies,
and a bunch of other things.
So I'm actually going to
reorganize this a little bit
like this.
The first category
is auth related,
and the second
category is going to be
the scheduling-related
primitives.
But it actually doesn't matter.
It's just so that we can
easily go through them.
So let me go through the
auth-related features first.
If you're familiar with
Kubernetes authentication,
authorization, and
admission, this
is basically how an object
comes to Kubernetes API,
and from the Kubernetes
API, makes it through etcd,
which is where it's stored.
You don't see the etcd in
Google Kubernetes Engine's case.
But basically, when you're
on your laptop or let's
say where there's a pod or a
program calling the Kubernetes
API, first we
authorize that request.
And the way we
authorize that request
is either through Kubernetes
RBAC or Google Cloud IAM.
In this case, if you're a
Google user, with your Gmail
or whatever, you can be
authorized through GKE
using the IAM authorizer.
And if you're not, if you're
like a Kubernetes service
account, which is like
some identity that
are given to pods, then you're
probably going through RBAC.
So if RBAC allows you,
then the next thing
is the admission control,
which we'll talk about later.
So let's dig a little bit
deep into the authorizer.
So Kubernetes RBAC is letting
you figure out which users
or which groups or which
service accounts have access
to which operations and
which API resources on which
namespaces.
So look a little bit deeper
into Kubernetes RBAC.
So two use cases
for Kubernetes RBAC
is you're either
giving people access
or you're giving Kubernetes
service accounts access.
And Kubernetes service
accounts are used by the pods.
So you might have some
controllers trying
to access your Kubernetes API.
And in this case, the API will
authorize a Kubernetes service
account.
So four key concepts
in Kubernetes RBAC
are cluster role,
which is you're just
defining a persona,
a set of permissions
that people can
use cluster-wide.
And there's a
namespace-scoped version
of that called just role.
And there is a
cluster role binding,
which lets you bind
cluster roles to users.
In this case, a user could
be just Google users,
Google groups, Cloud
IAM service accounts,
or again, Kubernetes
service accounts.
And the role binding is the
namespace version of that.
So here is an example, RBAC.
This must be the first
YAML we're seeing today.
This is the example
cluster role,
an example cluster role binding.
And if I look here, I'm defining
a namespace creator persona,
which is a namespace
creator cluster role.
And then this namespace creator
can do a get, list, watch,
create, delete, whatever
all these objects,
only on the namespace, right?
And when I go to the right side,
I see the cluster role binding.
And this cluster role binding is
assigned to a particular user.
That's my email address.
Don't send me spam, please.
So just like I'm adding
myself as a Google user,
I can add a group, I can add
a Kubernetes service account,
and so forth.
So this is how you
give access to someone
to do something on your
Kubernetes cluster using
Kubernetes RBAC.
So I'm going to jump
off RBAC, and I'm
going to talk a little
bit about the GKE IAM,
basically, how we do Cloud IAM.
This is a little bit different,
and it's an alternative
to Kubernetes RBAC.
So this is mostly practical for
giving Google users and Google
groups access to all
clusters in your project.
Let's say you
temporarily need to add
your colleagues to all clusters
as a viewer permission.
You can easily use that.
So we provide four IAM
roles today that we created.
Admin is like basically,
you can do everything.
Viewer is you can
view everything.
Cluster Admin is you can only
manage the cluster's lifecycle
and create, delete clusters
and upgrade them and so forth.
The developer is you just
look inside the cluster
and edit objects and create new
objects within that cluster,
and you don't know
about GKE at all,
so that's just
Kubernetes related.
And you can actually
use IAM custom roles
to curate your own
more interesting roles.
Again, like the
Namespace Admin I just
created using
Kubernetes RBAC, it
can also be created
using Cloud IAM.
So if you're interested
in project-wide access,
this is what you're looking at.
So an example of GKE IAM--
I'm sure if you're
actually using GKE,
you've probably
seen this before.
You know, you add an IAM
policy binding on the project.
You give some user
or a group access,
and you can specify
which role you want.
This is a gcloud CLI.
And next, I'm going to talk
about the admission controls.
Has anyone here actually written
an admission controller before?
I'm curious.
No, wow.
That's amazing.
So admission controllers are
a primitive in Kubernetes
that the requests go through.
So anytime you create
a pod, Kubernetes
calls a bunch of
admission plugins.
And each plugin tells Kubernetes
this pod is OK or not.
So any time it happens,
basically anytime you
submit a request
that is controlled
by a particular
admission plugin,
your request goes through a
bunch of admission plugins
like this.
So after the admission
plugins succeed--
they basically run in
serial one after another--
they go into the etcd and your
pod is created after that.
So admission
controls are actually
compiled into the
Kubernetes API server.
So this means you actually
cannot go and change
the admission plugins
that already exist.
And in Google
Kubernetes Engine, we
don't let you change the
admission plugins that
are already enabled.
So in this list,
you're basically
seeing 15 admission
plugins that probably
correspond to
Kubernetes features
that you might be already using.
So these are already
enabled on GKE today.
You know, the list may change
tomorrow, or in a new version.
But today, in a snapshot, it
basically looks like this.
So I said that admission
plugins are actually
compiled into the Kubernetes
binary, but you can--
I think as of Kubernetes
1.9 or something
like that-- you can write
your own Kubernetes admission
plugins.
And the way this works is you
create a pod, and then pod
goes through a bunch
of admission plugins.
And then there is
something called
mutating admission webhook.
And then that calls your webhook
that you might have registered,
and in that case, you actually
change the API objects
before they are created.
So let's say I'm
just trolling people.
And every time
they create a pod,
I'm going to change their pod
name, or something like that.
You can do something like this
using the mutating admission
webhooks.
And the validating
admission webhooks
are basically just if
the pod is good or not.
So you can write your
own admission plugin.
If the pod doesn't look good
to you, you can just reject it.
And the users will see
the rejection error
in their kubectl or whatever.
So this is a way to extend
Kubernetes authorization model.
If you don't want someone to
do something on your cluster,
and if the authorization
is not enough,
you can use the
admission controls
to enforce more strict
policies at your companies
by writing simple webhooks.
So let's talk a little bit
about the PodSecurityPolicy.
This is a relatively
new feature again.
This restricts host access, like
host file system, host network,
the ports, the
process ID namespace,
and stuff like that to the pods.
So let's say you want to
create a privileged container.
This actually prevents
you from stating
a policy that prevents
other people from creating
privileged containers.
So if you hate
privileged containers,
if you hate containers
running as root,
this is exactly what
you're looking for.
In this diagram, I'm looking at
the pod spec coming through--
coming to the admission
control in the API,
and then the admission control--
PodSecurityPolicy
admission controller
checks the pod security
specs that you have.
And then based on that,
it makes a decision.
Again, in this
example, on the left,
I have a PodSecurityPolicy
that this
allows the privileged
pods, and this allows
the pods running as root user.
And on the right,
on the bottom right,
I'm trying to deploy a pod
with security context that
has privileged equals true.
And this pod will be rejected.
So the next thing
is network policy.
This is, again, a
relatively new feature,
and I think about
six months ago,
this has gone GA on
Google Kubernetes Engine.
So this, again,
defines which pods
can talk to which other pods.
And this can be determined based
on which namespaces the pods
live on, or this can be
depending on what labels
the pods have, or you can
specify certain IP ranges that
the pods cannot talk
to or get traffic from.
So network policy is
basically a firewall
written in Kubernetes
language for your pods.
So we're offering this
through Calico Network Plugin.
If you will create a
cluster today with dash dash
enable network policy,
you'll be getting that.
An example network
policy I have here is
I'm selecting a bunch of
pods that have the label app
equals mysql--
you can see in the blue.
And then the next
thing I do is I allow--
the ingress keyword
here means "allow"--
traffic from the pods that have
the labels app equals frontend.
So in this case, my frontend
pods talk to my SQL pods.
So what I did was I
created a repository
for Kubernetes network
policies a while ago
at the previous KubeCon.
You can find the link here.
What I have in this
repository is just
a bunch of examples
of all the cool things
you can do with network
policy, and I really
encourage you to use
Kubernetes network policy,
because it is right
now not utilized well.
And it is pretty
good if you're just
looking for nonauthorization
and simple network firewalls.
So let's jump onto the
scheduling-related features.
The first one is pod
priority and preemption.
And the pod priority lets
you define a priority
that the pods get.
This is a numerical value.
And depending on
this numerical value,
the pods are scheduled
earlier than the pods
with the lower priority.
So let's say your
cluster is full,
and there is a scheduling queue.
The high-priority pod goes in
front of the scheduling queue,
and it gets scheduled first.
So if you have a bunch of
space issues in your cluster,
this kind of makes sure that
the high-priority pods actually
get run first.
And the pod preemption--
again, these features
are beta and going through
a beta in Kubernetes 1.11.
And pod preemption evicts
lower-priority pods
from a node.
So let's say your
cluster is full.
You don't have any more
space, but someone just
deployed something
super important,
like the high-priority
web frontend application.
It just released a new version,
and they need to scale up.
What happens is that the pod
preemption, which will again
come in 1.11, it's going to
evict the lower-priority pods
from the cluster.
And, again, you know,
this is depending
on the numerical value.
In this example here, I
have three priority classes
that I created, and
one of them is high.
You know, I just assigned
the value, like 1 million.
And then there is a normal.
It has a value of 1,000.
And then there is a
global default true.
This means that if I create
a priority class like this,
this global default true gets
applied to any pod created
by default. And then
the low has value 10,
and this is a
non-namespace object.
So when you apply this to your
cluster, everyone uses it.
So if you come up with certain
priorities at your company,
this is something that
you can directly utilize.
And I'm going to talk a little
bit about resource quotas.
This is probably the most
important policy object
if you're trying to limit
usage in your companies
in a single cluster.
So resource quotas
are per namespace.
It lets you limit the
total memory/cpu/storage
use and the load
balancer use and how many
pods a namespace can
have, how many config maps
or whatever a namespace
can have for each tenant.
So here's an example
resource quota.
In this resource quota, I'm
deploying these to the staging
namespace, and on the
left, I'm basically
saying, on this namespace,
you can have only 30 pods.
And you can have
two total services.
You cannot have services
with load balancer type,
because that load balancer
is a public load balancer.
If I know that this
team is not going
to need a public load balancer,
I can just disable that.
And I let this team use
five persistent volumes.
These are, on GKE, they're
like gcePersistentDisks,
which is a billable resource.
In this case, I
can kind of limit
the spending of this team.
And on the right, I have the
compute quota of this team.
I can say, I'm allocating eight
cores of CPU or 10 cores of CPU
if they're burstable to
this particular tenant.
And as far as the
RAM is concerned,
I'm allocating three gigabytes
of RAM to this tenant.
And, again, I have a
storage field here,
which basically says that the
total volume of the persistent
volume claims cannot
go over 120 gigabytes.
So resource quota
is fairly flexible
and lets you do stuff like that.
So as of Kubernetes 1.11,
some features going alpha,
and that feature is
I think Kubernetes
is allowing you to combine
resource quotas with priority
classes.
So if you ever
wondered, oh, what
if I want to set five CPUs for
my high-priority workloads,
that's exactly what
you're looking at.
So on the top left here, I
defined a low-priority class.
You know, we
defined that before.
And then here, I'm
basically creating a pod
with the priority class low.
That's an unimportant pod.
And on the right, I'm setting
a resource quota in this
namespace based on
the priority class,
so I'm saying that low-priority
class pods can have, in total--
I can have 100 of these
pods, and they can only
use a total of 10 CPUs.
And [INAUDIBLE] you
go buy some memory.
So one of the most
important features
you're probably going
to go home and try out
is the Pod Anti-Affinity.
So this feature, basically,
if you don't want to co-locate
tenants on a single node--
for instance, a lot
of finance companies
have this requirement--
this is kind of what
you're looking for.
Pod Anti-Affinity lets you use
constraints, such as labels,
to prevent scheduling
on certain nodes.
In this example, I
have a pod that says,
the label has team
equals billing.
And on the right,
I have another pod
that is specifying a
Pod Anti-Affinity role.
And I'm saying that look
at the Kubernetes hostname.
This is the node name, right?
And in this nodename,
don't put me
on a node that does not
have another pod that
has the billing label.
So this lets you, again,
flexibly use these clusters.
So anytime someone you
know gets scheduled there,
the next thing you
do is another pod
that comes in basically
trusts this model.
And then it will not get
scheduled by Kubernetes
under any circumstance
to that node.
Another concept that you
might utilize, especially
if you have different sorts of
hardware in your data center,
is dedicated nodes.
Let's say you have a
machine learning team.
They ordered a bunch
of GP nodes, right?
Or they're already
using GP nodes
on Google Kubernetes Engine.
And in this case, you
can reserve these nodes
for the machine learning
team, and then no one else
will be able to schedule to it.
And the way this works is we're
using taints and tolerations
feature on Google
Kubernetes Engine.
So normally what you do is you
run the command kubectl taint
node and then
specify the nodename
to put a taint on the node.
But in GKE case, you can
directly apply these tenants
to the node pools.
So anytime the node
pool scales up,
or a node gets removed
because of other repair
or a scale-down
event or something
like that, all of the nodes
in that node pool will always
have this team equals
machine-learning NoSchedule
tenant.
So GKE offers you this
flexibility to do that.
And as far as the
tolerations are concerned,
any pod that wants to
schedule on this node
needs to have this
particular toleration.
As you see on the bottom
right, that's saying,
machine-learning
effect NoSchedule.
And you know, the team
equals machine-learning
I'm going to use the
effect NoSchedule.
So when you use
that, your pod gets
scheduled onto the GPU node.
So again, I'm going
to call Yoshi to here,
and he's going to talk about
Sandboxed pods and gVisor.
YOSHI TAMURA: Thank you, Ahmet.
Awesome.
Before I actually jump
in, how many of you
actually came to my
gVisor talk, which
happened like 30 minutes ago?
So half?
OK, great.
So for those, sorry,
it's going to be
a little bit of repetition.
But if you have any
questions later,
we could definitely
talk about it.
So Sandboxed pods, I'm going to
talk about a lot of primitives
that we have today in Kubernetes
and Kubernetes Engine.
Sandboxed pods is
something that we
are building today and
hopefully to address
the fundamental problem around
a container isolation boundary.
There are two
approaches right now,
which we're going to
talk to you guys about.
But before that, there are two.
One is-- Kata Container
is one that will hopefully
work with the Sandbox pod API.
And we have gVisor as a
runtime for the Sandbox API.
The concept of Sandbox is really
about making containers really
contain to address
the threat that's
coming from inside, which we'll
talk for now very shortly.
So gVisor, this is the Google
approach to the Sandbox pods.
So gVisor is a
kind of new runtime
for containers to really make it
contained inside this Sandbox.
Today, when you run
containers, containers
will directly interact
with the host Linux
kernel and the system interface
there, like sys calls and slash
[INAUDIBLE] system.
You have a very huge
attacking surface there.
And if a malicious application
inside the container
exploits the bugs in the
kernel and then escapes
that container, then basically--
and then the privileged
discussion happens,
then basically your system
could be compromised.
Now, as you can see
from this diagram,
gVisor will sit in the
middle, and it by itself
is an independent kernel.
It implements the Linux
system calls in user space.
By saying that, what
I mean by the user
space is that container would
still think that, oh, my system
calls are handled properly,
but what it's actually
interacting with is the
system that the user
in the independent kernel that
is running inside the user
space.
So what's going to happen is
that, even if the gVisor--
well, it's just one other
software-- has a vulnerability,
and this malicious
software happened
to be able to take advantage
of that and breaks in.
Now, what's going to happen is
that basically, it only just
broke the one boundary.
You'll still have
another boundary
between gVisor and kernel.
Another aspect about
gVisor is that there
are a lot of tools that
would harden Linux and reduce
a system surface, such as
seccomp filter and SELinux.
The challenge there
is that you do
need to know what you're
doing for your application
and your users.
And even if you're
able to do so,
it doesn't mean that
you can use the policy
for every application.
You have to mandate
that to the application
to follow that guideline,
or then you can lower--
or you lower the bar.
So what's going to
happen, and frequently is
that if you try to
cover more application,
more use cases, then you'll step
back, step back a little bit.
And then you have much more less
described in policies or rules
there.
On the other hand,
it's definitely
going [INAUDIBLE] to
actually come off with that.
Now, on the other
hand, gVisor, it
does not have any configuration.
We'll look into it later.
But from an
application standpoint,
you can bring in, you know,
basically any application
on top of gVisor and run on
top, and you have to modify it.
But gVisor itself is written
in Go language, which
is the memory and type safe.
That's much more
stronger language
to describe the system
component like gVisor.
So gVisor on
Kubernetes, how it's
going to look like
from an architecture
perspective, gVisor is
going to provide a Sandbox.
But on top of that,
we have runsc,
which is OCI runtime that is
actually powered by gVisor.
So Kubernetes could be talking
into this runsc by OCI,
or even Docker can talk
to the runsc by OCI.
As I mentioned,
so underneath it,
there is-- your container will
be running inside a Sandbox.
And you'll see, in
this case, the sentry,
the user LAN kernel
of gVisor, is
wrapping around that container.
And then there is
another filter,
which is seccomp plus
namespace underneath Sentry,
which we call another boundary.
So basically, one
isolation and two
isolation boundaries,
second and first and second.
To show how it kind of works,
when your container makes
a system call, then it
will be trapped by the-- so
we call it a kind of platform.
I show KVM here, but we
also have [INAUDIBLE]..
Your sys call will be
captured and forwarded
to the user LAN kernel.
So this is a first key.
Instead of implementing the
system call in the kernel,
it goes back to the
user LAN and then
it's implemented as
much as possible.
There are cases to implement--
Sentry has to call
the system call
to implement the
request of sys call,
but we significantly
filter the actual system
call that Sentry is going
to make to the Linux kernel.
And that's exactly where
seccomp comes into play,
and it's surrounded
by namespace.
It's around like
10 to 20 sys call
compared to the full 320-ish
sys call stats exposed
in the regular Linux kernel.
So it's much more restricted.
File I/O and Network
is also another service
we have to take care of.
By default, your container
will not have direct access
to the host file system.
Everything will be handled
by so-called Gofer, which
will handle the
file and networking,
and we have 9P protocol to
connect Gofer and Sentry there.
So this is, like I mentioned,
the Sandbox pod in Kubernetes.
This is exactly
what we're working.
We're leading effort
in the community.
It is a work in progress, so
it's not something available
yet.
But I think we have
a very final stage
of the spec at this moment.
Actually, this is really my
third time revising this stack,
so what I'm showing
now is the latest one.
There's no guarantee that
it's not going to change.
I'm pretty sure that things
will change along the way.
So just treat it as a
grain of salt. And also,
unlike Ahmet's awesome
YAML file [INAUDIBLE],,
I'm just going to take advantage
of that to say very simple,
short YAML file for my talk.
So a runtime class
is the new API
to specify runtime so that
we can implement this concept
called Sandbox pods.
The left side of this YAML
file is the actual way
to specify the runtime class,
and you can see the meta name.
So this runtime class
will be named gVisor,
and inside there, there's a
runtime handler called gVisor.
Inside this runtime
handler, you can
specify the actual executable
file and all the parameters
in there.
But we believe that this
left side, the specifying
a runtime class part, will be
defined by the Cluster Admin.
Or in case of Cloud, like
us, Kubernetes Engine,
will be us who will be defining
the runtime class for you.
And from a user perspective,
all you have to do
is to specify
which runtime class
you want to use for your pod.
So on the right side,
you can see this.
All you have to do is just
write your regular pod,
and then say, runtime class name
gVisor, which is provided by--
which is defined by
the left-hand side.
So it's very straightforward.
All righty, so we talked
about multi-tenancy,
and Ahmet talked
about and discussed
and hopefully introduced you
to what are the things needed
to use multi-tenancy.
But there are some areas
that we're still working on,
and where the community
is still working on.
So I wanted to quickly
go through that.
Policy management.
I think this is really,
perhaps only myself,
but when Ahmet was talking
about RBAC and policy and all
the admin files, you have
to know what you need to do.
And doing just one is
already complicated enough.
But if you're responsible for
providing such an environment
for a larger organization,
with many, many projects,
yes, it's not going to
be necessarily scalable.
It is a challenge to make sure
that IAM policy is up to date,
right?
Once you define it, great.
But how do you know
that is actually
still consistent
in the long run,
and/or like a different
projects routine?
So that will be the
challenge, and I'm
very excited to introduce
this Kubernetes Engine Policy
Management.
This is very new, alpha.
This is the product that my
colleagues are working on.
And unfortunately, we have
this kind of colliding,
so the talk is now
happening in Moscone South,
so I will strongly
recommend to watch the video
once it gets uploaded.
But I was just going to tell
you the nutshell, because I
had a chance to understand the
vision from the TL and the PMs
yesterday.
So like I mentioned, the
policy management and scaling,
that is very, very challenging.
So the ideal vision here
is that all you have to do
is come to the Kubernetes
Cloud [INAUDIBLE]..
And when you specify the project
from your organization folder,
if you opt in, once
you create a project,
it will automatically create a
namespace inside your cluster
for you.
So like team building
or team development.
Once you do that, it will
always create a namespace
with that particular
labeling so that you
don't have to worry about it.
So the larger
vision is that, yes,
you can specify a lot of
those policies here and there,
but isn't it much more
effective and ideal
developer and user experience
if we could provide
a cohesive kind of view there?
And that's what it's all about
with this Kubernetes Engine
Policy Management.
So two things.
So the talk I/O
200 happening now.
I strongly recommend watching
this once it gets uploaded.
Also, this is in alpha.
They absolutely want somebody
to sign up and also feedback,
so please come to this, click,
go through this sign-up form
if you're interested in
scaling your policy management.
Also, Kubernetes multi-tenancy
has some limitation.
One is that for now, the API
calls are not rate limited.
So you can see that this could
be perhaps one of the attacking
surface, and we need to
address that in the long run.
And also, networking is also
not kind of scheduled resources
yet, so we do need
to figure out what
will be the right way to kind
of slice our networking resource
and attach it to the namespace.
And also, tenants
can still discover
each other via the
Kubernetes DNS,
so these are at a kind
of a high-level control
plane, robustness and
isolation that we will probably
need if we want to implement
the full Kubernetes
multi-tenancy, the model
that Ahmet introduced earlier
in his slides.
OK, so key takeaway for the
multi-tenancy in general.
First, define it.
It's a very kind
of rule of thumb,
but I think it's very important.
Determine your use case.
Is your user coming from
outside your organization
or inside your organization?
That's one way to look at it.
But perhaps much more
[INAUDIBLE],, how trusted
are your tenant and
users and workflows?
This is actually
perhaps more important.
If you trust everyone
correctly, and if you
trust whatever software
that they're going to bring,
I think you have a
better position not
to use all the isolation
mechanism or policy
intensively.
But if not, you
do need something.
And related to that, what sort
of a degree of isolation do you
want to have?
Is it per the cluster level,
or the taint and toleration
that I'm going to talk about?
You know, it's node level.
Or we actually want to
even split inside a node.
And if you're looking for
that, yes, Sandbox pod
will be definitely something
you want to think about.
And the namespace-specific
multi-tenancy, we do
understand, as of now,
that namespace is still
perhaps a newer concept.
For those who are already
kind of using namespace,
I think it's totally fair
to think that namespace
is the kind of
starting point to think
about the multi-tenancy in
Kubernetes and Kubernetes
Engine.
But I also understand that there
are people who are actually
running multi-tenancy
services, so Team A, Team B
running on the same cluster,
but not using namespace.
That's totally fine, but I
definitely do recommend using--
considering namespace
moving forward.
And here, we wanted to utilize
a policy object and scheduling
and access control.
And also, think
about the persona
and how you want it to map
into the RBAC roles in there.
And if you have more
complicated-- now, of course,
the problem is very complex
enough for a single cluster.
But if you actually do want to
have more robust and great user
experience from single
cluster to multiple cluster,
the GKE, Google Kubernetes
Engine Policy Management
that has been announced now
will be a great choice for you.
So I strongly recommend
looking into this.
OK, so that's it, I think.
So, Ahmet, you wanted to talk
about the call for actions.
AHMET ALP BALKAN:
Yeah, in this case,
we want you to
bring your opinions
to the multi-tenancy space.
So for that, I'll keep this
slide up for a bit so you can
take a picture of that and go
to gke.page.link/multi-tenancy.
And fill out this form to
register your interest.
What do you want to see?
What is your use case?
We really want to
hear about this.
And in the open
source community,
the work is still happening.
When we looked at the
Kubernetes space a year ago,
there were only a few
of the policy objects
that we were talking
about, and now we're
at a state where most of
the policy objects are in--
some of them are already GA,
such as the resource quota.
And some of them are going
beta, and some of them
are coming up very
recently as alpha.
So we want also
you to, if you're
interested in this
space, we want
you to participate in the
open source community.
So most prominently, the
relevant working group
in Kubernetes space is going
to be the multi-tenancy working
group.
And in this case,
this work group
is led by engineers from
Google and Microsoft.
And you know, you can find links
here to join this work group.
Similarly, the policies
are very key to Kubernetes
multi-tenancy, and the
Kubernetes policy working group
is looking at these
sort of policies.
Basically, how we can use the
namespace logical boundary
and take it to a
place where people
can use it to
achieve multi-tenancy
in their clusters.
Again, the Kubernetes
policy working group
is a pretty fun
place to hang out.
I would totally recommend
reading their design docs.
And there are two
other working groups
that I have not listed here.
One of them is SIG Auth,
which looks at authorization
and authentication.
If you're interested in RBAC and
IAM and how these things work,
and if you want to
bring, I don't know,
your own YDC provider
and stuff like
that, if you want to provide
opinions in that area,
SIG Auth is where
you should look at.
Again, another one
is SIG Scheduling.
As the name indicates,
they bring a lot of stuff
from the policy work
group, and already
stuff that exists in
Kubernetes, such as I've
talked about how the pod
preemption and pod priorities
work.
This is SIG scheduling, so you
should definitely check out
the SIG Scheduling as well.
If you're generally interested
in distributed systems
scheduling space, SIG
Scheduling, again,
is a nice place to hang out.
And there are a lot of
interesting design docs there.
So this concludes our talk.
Thanks again for coming up.
Again, this link is still
going to be there, so feel
free to take pictures of that.
If you have questions, I think
we have only a few minutes.
But we can get
questions at the mic,
but we'll make ourselves
available here after the talk
as well.
So please don't hesitate
to ask your questions.
Again, thank you very much.
YOSHI TAMURA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]